[Music]
joining me today is an author a
commentator a screenwriter and a pilot
oh well welcome to the Rubin report good
to be here Dave took long enough it
didn't take long enduring the distance
we had to travel to get here I had no
idea I don't want to give it anything
away related to our location we will not
be we are too under to undisclosed
locations that are probably 400 yards
apart from each other something like
yeah completely ridiculous
there is a food place which we're not
going to describe where later we could
possibly break bread sweet wouldn't it
that would be bread we would break there
would be wood kept of it I don't want to
say anything else all right
I'm looking forward to talking to you I
was on your show a couple weeks ago we
have a story a great discussion about
the things that I really care about
about freedom about Liberty about how we
should be governed about ways that we
shouldn't be governed and all sorts
other stuff and especially about the
idea that people should not only should
be allowed to but the entire thesis of
this country is disagreement right and
that's the entire reason we're here
should be able to discuss things I I
think I said on the show and I certainly
mean it when somebody makes a case it's
compelling enough for me I'll change my
mind and I feel bigger person I feel I
feel like I come out of that larger yes
all right so let's start right there
what happened what went wrong seemingly
in the last couple years we're sitting
down from someone that you disagree with
and agreeing to disagree or just not
agreeing to disagree but going okay I
can still win the country with that
person what where did that go where did
that start crumbling when did it click
well first of all I think I think
there's you could probably make the case
that in terms of what the other side
doesn't like you kind of started this
pendulum and rather than the pendulum
damping out has just gotten wider and
wider and wider right so so you know
there's a there's Regan and they didn't
like Regan so Bill Clinton could serve
as didn't like Clinton to the George
Bush in love with her and then Barack
Obama and now Donald Trump is just
things just going to the building's
going to come apart but I think the
primary thing that's changed is that
politics is in so much more of our life
than it used to be seems to me that I
didn't know I didn't know if my dad was
a Republican or Democrats I was probably
20 18 19 20
I just didn't care and I didn't think
about Paul
Dick's in any way shape or form until I
was 43 so all of all of the things that
used to be political
we're not things that you get
particularly ginned up about you know
somebody's going to make a trade
agreement with China and if your
neighbor thinks it should be 13% you and
you're one of the 24% people you're not
likely to lose Thanksgiving dinners over
those things right but as politics is
pressed itself out into everything else
in the entire culture now everything is
political and you find yourself on these
on these sides of issues and sometimes
occasionally you find yourself arguing
against things that you actually kind of
support just because you know it's
coming from the other team and it's
getting really out of hand
yeah so you weren't political know you
were 43 yeah which is really fascinating
and I want to get to that but that you
didn't know the weather your father was
a Democrat Republican is kind of
interesting tell me a little bit about
growing up well my dad was a hotel
manager as born in Manhattan and we live
just across River in in West New York
just a couple of yards from where Aaron
Burr when I all right and just before my
first birthday we moved to Bermuda so I
grew up in Bermuda and I actually kind
of grew up in the best corner of Grenada
like my dad was pretty solidly middle
class I don't think I was quite shocked
as an adult when I found out he never
made more than forty four thousand
dollars he really is really quite a
shock for me but there were a lot of
great perks with it and growing up on
what pink beaches of permute it was
pretty nice but the main thing about
that experience was the British schools
which are were anyway exceptional
extraordinary they were highly
disciplined very structured but they
were also very competitive very
competitive and I just took to that and
and it gave me a four or five year boost
in terms of education but socially was
probably a five-year anchor University I
was all very school so suddenly you
arrived in Miami and you're fearing for
your life you have this funny accent you
don't carry your book right you know and
yeah so so it was it was a real
transformative experience for me and
then what took you another 23 years to
get into politics well I
I had seen the Thunderbirds but my dad
was very busy man because a hotel
manager is a day job and a night job run
the hotel during the day came home take
an hour to nap and then go down and
entertain the guests so he definitely
see the Thunderbirds out at Kimmi Air
Force Base in 165 I guess flying up one
hundreds and I just dropped my ice cream
cone I never really pick it up you know
I mean honestly as what
so between ages of 5 and 17 I was just I
was just going to go I was going to be
an astronaut I was serious about it I
got a job at the Miami planetarium when
I was 13 I think
I was running shows and teaching
astronomy there from 14 and everything's
looking good and I went to take the
vision test as part of the physical sail
through everything else and even know I
had a vision problem until I failed the
vision test and that was it that was it
and needless to say I spent the that
summer between junior and senior year in
college just wandering around like a
somebody been clubbed on the head you
know I've been with the house for well
yeah that must be I mean I didn't know
exactly what I always tell you I see I
sometimes still I don't know exactly
what I want to do but I can only imagine
being what's at 17 days and that's right
and and suddenly your dreams are crushed
by something that you simply cannot
control yeah and I've been after these
for quite a long time but that that's
exactly and by the way that's a really
interesting point because that aspect of
my life has been a big influence on a
lot of the political thinking I do that
that idea that you know that that nobody
that the world did not owe me the Air
Force Academy the world didn't only Mars
mission all the things I thought I was
going to do it didn't all those things
to me I was heartbroken by it but that's
the way it goes and parenthetically just
very quickly what I did find out about
life is that you know you can't always
get what you want but sometimes you know
try real hard you can get what you needs
so I don't think there's a song about
that if not I suspect I've made up you
do not on certainly I'm quite certain I
came up with it but but so I you know I
wanted to fly f-16s and I can't fly
f-16s and I never will but I have a
little experimental airplane with a
propeller in the back so I don't have to
see it and I go through the air at 200
miles an hour and I make my fighter
pilot turns and and it's good enough so
that is the pilot that I mentioned
earlier yeah that's a big part of my
personality and but it's a really
interesting point for me because there's
very few people in life would they get
exactly what they want but if you are
dealt cards that prevents that you can
still get pretty close I know that mean
the number of people playing NBA
basketball it's a percentage of
population as you can see where I would
rather be than here exactly
probably the only place that I'd write
exam here would be if I could be in the
NBA okay so you don't get a chance to
play in the NBA and that's the card
you're dealt with and there's nothing
you can do about that but you do get to
play basketball and if you really really
like playing basketball you could play
league basketball with guys that are
really really good and it's it's it's
enough it is for me anyway yeah yeah
well that's what it's all about right
sort of going as hard as you can but
then realizing where the limits might be
and then figuring out how to max that
out whatever that means do you enjoy and
skill or yeah I I learned very late also
probably only three or four years ago
somebody told me that the that the
ancient Greek definition of happiness
was using all of your abilities to their
fullest and I thought that's really true
yeah you know you know you know when
you're doing good work and you know when
you're doing bad work but you know when
you're doing good work and when you do
things that that you put a lot of effort
into and especially when you work really
hard for goals for a long period of time
if there's no feeling like it if it's
the reason so reason makes me feel human
yeah that would be a good segue to where
I want to go in a little bit about you
know building your own thing and having
your own platform and doing this on your
own outside of mansion we're going to
get there but I want to hear about this
forty three-year-old episode what
happened you're 43 years old yeah you're
doing your thing
well because suddenly well the air force
thing happened between my junior and
senior year in college and I had some
friends basically took pity on me and
they dragged me out into the Florida
summer and we started making super 8
movies and it gave me a chance to a
little clowning around and I guess it's
just a natural Hammond pose and stuff
certainly looking most of my videos are
really that's probably putting it mildly
yeah but it was actually fun and and we
took it real seriously we did we did
a lot of story and cuts and you know we
didn't just turn on the camera we took
it like real movies and then I realized
that when I went for my senior year in
high school that all all the girls who
had who had wanted nothing to do with
mr. calculator on his belt turtleneck in
the Florida summer you know it's a
science dork yeah all of a sudden you're
making movies everybody wants to be in
them you know and you're getting invited
to parties and people should now you're
actually kind of funny it's again so
funny last year too and and so there was
that reward turtleneck in Florida if you
have no idea don't even the calculator I
don't even start me it's all part of the
it's all part of the outer shell of
vanity that that makes my life what it
is but but but truthfully I mean it was
it was when I say was a role it was an
identity and and it was very important
to me and then I became a theater major
at the University of Florida friend of
mine who's a year older who was baking
the movies just goof around once
universe of Florida got a degree theatre
he said you can come up just kind of
weekend with the mist you can actually
do this for he couldn't agree in this
yeah yeah financially well damn you know
so I was a theater major and I was very
left-wing I would say very left-wing and
over time I just I just started reading
all kinds of other different things and
never was really a moment so I was I was
considered a Republican by the people I
was working with but I didn't know much
about anything 9/11 turned a lot of
people but it didn't turn me what turned
me was right after 9/11 about nine
months later my dad died and he was
interred at Arlington which is shocking
because he was never war hero is never
shot at he got the Germany in the last
week of the war I think but I found
myself out there on an October morning
I've never been that cold in my life and
you're walking the Rose of Arlington and
all of the headstones are exactly the
same and here's a major-general has been
in phenol world war one world war two
Korea Vietnam Gulf Iran here's a guy who
just do the math he's a sergeant Lee
views in less than a year maybe and this
was in October of 2002 when a lot of the
push back was starting all we deserved
9/11 it was our fault you know and I
just remember thinking that my dad who
had been such a such an asset as a
businessman
over time it just basically didn't get
fired on the phone but 40 40 some years
after he signed on the dotted line along
with everybody else you know they turn
out here's 20 guys in the army band
here's another 20 guys in the army honor
guard and the caisson and everything
it's freezing cold these guys are at
attention they're the same age as he was
when he signed on the dotted line and I
thought a country that keeps its
promises like that that keeps those
fundamental promises is is is worth
defending so I I wrote a just a very
brief two-page thing to a guy whose blog
I admired very much at the time guy
named Stephen dead best and he said you
mind if I print this and okay sure and
got a lot of attention and it's
something else that got attention and
Rachel Lucas set me up with a with a
blog and I started a blog called eject
eject eject and I didn't write about
politics at all I wrote about philosophy
and I wrote about morality I wrote got
to be a kekkaishi I guess but I wrote as
is called um courage and responsibility
power honor freedom history those kind
of things yeah any learning issues it's
interesting to me because when I was on
your show just a couple weeks ago we did
we did a full hour and there we didn't
prepare before you even question me
before but I knew that you know we can
add a couple times and I knew that we're
you know we have a good conversation but
we barely talked politics in the
traditional sense when I get a little
more of this where we're talking about
the ideas around politics that sort of
frame it that's that's always what I'm
interested in I sense that's what you're
interested in so why is that why isn't
it about the minutiae there's so many
people lost I think in the minutiae of
the day-to-day politics screaming about
this immediate decision or Trump tweeted
this today it's very reactive reaction
yeah exactly the reaction to this I find
the only way to make sense of it is to
try to care about the stuff that really
is the underpinning of it absolutely
right and and one of the reasons I was
looking forward to coming here and
talking to you and we did the election
night thing as well is because there's a
great deal about civility GONOW people
can make a legitimate claim that you
know I'm advancing the loss of civility
because I do a
a number of videos where I point out
things that I don't think the by the way
just one about why I got a pretty good
job however in mine out there is I think
they called it they knew I was going to
be on her Thunderbirds story you guys
are four and half minutes late
but they it's it's about the philosophy
and it's about the ability to disagree
about things and and to be honest with
you I'm ready to talk to anybody who's
ready to make an argument you know and
out and not just launch all the vitriol
but but I I try very very very hard to
get things right and before I ever go on
camera or do anything I really do kind
of preflight these ideas I kind of walk
around so what if you wrongly write
about this you know are you are you are
you cherry-picking data are you aware
that you might be cherry-picking data
without even knowing it and if I make a
spelling mistake it makes me sick you
know it just it just makes me ill yeah
one of the things that we talked about a
couple weeks ago is that I said to you
that I've never blatantly lied on this
show that's right I have made mistakes
right without question we've had times
where I've made a mistake and I told my
guys after leave it in because I want
I'll comment that in the comments and
say you know I screwed this up yeah but
I want people to see that I'm as human
as anyone else in anything but I would
never intentionally mislead or
intentionally lie but even that that
seems like such a big thing these days
when it's actually such a small thing
yeah and that's probably the most the
single most common word applied to
people in terms of criticism of their
politics on YouTube comments or whatever
you know lier that's a lie lie lie lie
lie
I can also stand here and tell you same
as you I have never told a lie on those
shows that doesn't mean I've never been
wrong but it means I have never gone out
there knowing something was untrue and
said it as if it was true
yeah that goes to so much of what's
wrong with mainstream media right now
which I know you're we're very much
simpatico on that a lot of the
mainstream media stuff so the night that
we first met was election I we were over
the Daily wire offices and they had some
beers and Shapiro was there and clave
and a couple other guys Shapiro was sort
of vacillating back and forth between he
was thrilled that Hillary wasn't
president but sort of horrified the
Trump was a friend I thought it was
vacillating between being really upset
the Trump want and being a little bit
upset the Trump won but but yeah he was
here after he was out here vibrating
however you want to partying and I had
never seen him in that position before
Clavin I think was a little and I had
him out a couple weeks ago he was more
okay with Trump but you were you were
elated that night and you were the first
person that I saw and it was because it
was happening that night and I happened
to be in a room with you you were the
first person that I saw that was like
this is this is it this is what I wanted
like you know a night had Milo on in
Serna [ __ ] and Scott Adams other
supporters but I happened to be with you
that night are you are you as elated
eight months later well I am but but
probably almost certainly for reasons
that you that you don't suspect
I wasn't elated that Donald Trump was
elected because I was a Donald Trump in
I was never a Donald Trump fan when
people asked me for the first six months
of this thing what do you like about say
one thing I like about Donald Trump I
said I liked his had you know I've
pretty much it
and all throughout the debates and so on
and and and so I was never like a Trump
guy I was I was a real solid you know I
was I was a Ted Cruz guy mm-hmm
but I wasn't elated about the night
because Donald Trump won I was elated
about the night because there was still
room for choice in the American
political system that this thing was not
on a rail that this media bias was not
something that was insurmountable there
still was a chance to get off of the
track of history that had been written
out for for pretty much the whole
country I don't think it was going to
win I didn't think it was going to win
at all
and the main reason I was as happy as I
was to be honest with you is is because
uh my fiancee is from Russia and when
she cannot well the fiance is oh is it
open air when she came over here sure
yeah but when she did this before the
Russian thing happened because that all
happened post-election
to two nights after the election Hillary
says fake news Russia connection
Elizabeth but she came over from Russia
and and we went to a debate watching the
first debate with a bunch of
conservatives here in Los Angeles there
were three of us I suspect maybe Jerry
20:25 vineyard and in that first debate
Trump was landing these these bees let's
not say he was landing any blows but he
was counter-attacking with enthusiasm
let's at least put it that way and
people were cheering and and she looked
at me and said why is everybody so
excited as honey bees are these are
important issues this is really really
important and it was impossible for her
to really realize on the spot
that we take it as weight that we that
there is in fact a choice there's no
politics in Russia right the people
don't have any middle talk politics in
Russia because it doesn't make any
difference what your politics are in
Russia Putin's going to do what he wants
to do and that's the way it is the idea
that people would have an emotional
vested interest in the outcome of this
meant that the outcome was in doubt and
and as the as the primary went on and as
the other as the rest of the election
season went on and so on it just began
to look like that kind of head wing was
just insurmountable but the Clinton you
know the Clinton machine and and and and
the media coverage and everything was
just not going to be possible but no he
was never Mike Kennedy he's not my
candidate now he is he is to me the only
person that is capable of destroying the
the media information complex and what
comes with that I'll take and it's so
interesting that so many people are
putting such a high premium on that
including Andrew Clavin who we were with
that night and one of the things that he
said that evening that did help me frame
this a little bit more was he said what
a beautiful country we live in that all
the pundits could be wrong yeah all of
the peak the money and the power in the
elite they all said this is going to
happen all the polls said this is going
to happen and the reverse happened that
actually shows you the strength of our
democracy and the beauty of the power to
the people absolutely right and this is
my entire theory of what what I try to
defend is I had when I was in my 20s and
30s certainly right after I started
making movies and stuff
colleges in college I was exceedingly
unpleasant prison I really was I was so
I was so obsessed with intelligence I
was so obsessed with you know looking
smart being smart and and I was so sure
of myself and I had that beaten out of
me over the course of you know 25 30
years 30-plus years of being a limo
driver a security guard waiter you know
all these things and I got to I got to
be in show business that came out here
as an editor and I'm hanging around very
you know sophisticated people and very
beautiful people and and some
celebrities and things like that and
when I was speaking in event early in my
career and I'll just tell you the story
straight up I was at an event afterwards
I make it a point to be the last person
out of the room you know they're going
to fly me out there and people are going
to come and see me I'm the last guy out
so I was talking to everybody and and a
guy came up to me and honest to god he
looked like jr. samples from he yeah
he's a big guy he was wearing the the
the the overalls you know the coveralls
and he just he looked like junior
samples from he huh and I had this
thought right right then I thought you
know it'd be nice flow as a you know if
I was a leftist and I could get all this
kind of you know more glamorous people
in Hollywood crowd in the hole and just
flow with the entire pop culture and
then right on the heels of that wasn't
later anything just like this lightning
bolt like I'd shocked myself you know I
remember thinking dude this man knows a
hundred things more than you do better
than you hundred things he knows better
than you do and there's probably two or
three things if this guy's knows that
making pretty near an expert in the
world now that maybe just things like at
what temperature milk because it congeal
or whatever but don't don't go there
this was an enormous breakthrough for me
and and it's been something I've tried
to keep myself honest with very very
long time and very carefully it's the
idea that there is a reservoir of
knowledge in the population of America
and that it's not based entirely on
education fact it's not based mostly on
education it is a fundamental decency
and a fundamental sense of what works
and what doesn't and I got tired of
those people being demonized I got tired
of
being being assaulted by people with
very high rhetorical skill and and very
good-looking on camera and very big love
loudspeakers but I got tired of it and
it doesn't strike me as fair and I and I
what I learned from this day is I
learned that rhetorical ease and
intelligence are not the same thing
they look like they're the same thing to
some people but they're not the same
thing they're different yeah that's so
interesting to me because we both were
born in New York we both now live in LA
and yet I feel what you're saying very
intimately that always became obvious to
me when I started interviewing people I
start getting emails from people in the
middle of the country and they'd say
Dave it doesn't sound like you're
judging us everyone else is judging us I
don't think well I don't think I'm
better than you
somebody just doing the best I can you
know and that's it I mean that's it I
hope I'm bringing some goodness here and
try and do the best I can but I don't
feel that I have some magic wisdom that
they don't have I think if anything they
might have some magic with that I don't
notice Eisley right which is why which
is why my favorite part of the speaking
events is the QA because ivory I love if
you like FARC yeah first of all if you
can get a question you've never heard
before and you can answer it on the fly
yeah that means you understand your
philosophy because many questions you've
dealt with before so you have kind of a
canned answer it's the only way to think
about you yeah comedian you write jokes
if you're a musician singsong if you're
funded you have answers to things that
you get a lot but but when I get a
question that I literally stumps me I
realize for me person I said well what's
the freedom answer here what's what is
the freedom answer here and that almost
always takes me to the right place and
so I enjoy that aspect of it but I
learned so much from the people and one
of the things that I learn a lot from I
don't do many of them just haven't but
when I go to very liberal schools I have
a very steep learning curve as a result
of my interaction with the audience
which is important and I suspect and
probably enjoy I do I'm not wired for
patience as a general rule but I had an
experience
East Texas this just last winter and I
got to this event and I started speaking
and I think I might have mentioned we
did a whole segment on this matter of
fact and there's a guy in the front row
who had started a Facebook page to have
me banned from certain area yeah and I
said if you know if you imagine the COTS
kid growing up in Malibu that's what
this guy looked like so Malibu Trotsky
yelling over I mean I'm using yelling
over everything I'm trying to say and to
my absolute astonishment
I just got serene I mean I went past
comment just kind of the Zen tranquility
you know and and I just let him go and
let him go and go and go and go and go
and go and people would ask me questions
a lot of antagonism about the questions
and I'd start asking people about trying
to find what we have in common maybe
agreeing maybe nodding and I think
Malibu Trotsky looked around and said
well he's actually having a conversation
with these people that I brought down to
boo him off the stage and then he
started criticizing me you and your
epilogue answers you know what is it
with all these long anywhere
deregulation and your explanations for
your behavior it's the the the big
breakthrough for me and I and from from
the time I've been doing progressive
events I don't do many of them probably
done six or seven colleges is that I
thought I would go in there and I
thought that my mission doing I don't
think I'd change anybody's mind but I
thought at the very least my mission is
to go in there and explain these
principles in such a way that people can
understand them just give it to them the
way it is not not the way people tell
them I won't tell them what I think not
not let them hear what other people
think that I think but I found out very
early in all of these cases that my
primary result was that by the time it
was over people said well he strikes me
as a human being anyway you know he
strikes me as a human being he's a
conservative so obviously he wants to
see poor people just dying in the gutter
but he strikes me as a person who
doesn't want to see people dying in the
gutter and turns out I don't
and so this moral preening that causes
test tropic events downstream is the one
thing that I have genuine hatred for is
when people will will puck themselves up
about taking a position
that's one thing but when you pop
yourself up about all the good you're
doing when in point of fact the
downstream effects that are catastrophic
murderous ruinous dead people ruin lives
and you don't want to look at that you
want to you want to instead just have a
good feeling of feeling like you're
doing the right thing that's when I get
religion yeah well that's what is
perfect way to end that sense it's
because it's an odd moral position that
they've put themselves in the same way
you know we've said this on the show a
bunch lately but this this progressivism
has become a secular religion in a lot
of respects and uncoupling that or at
least dealing with those people can be
tough and I think maybe we're you've
probably made some headway and I think
where I've made a little bit of headway
is that if you keep pushing the ideas if
I'm for your liberty I'm for your
freedom I'm for you to live your life
the way you want but then that comes
with having other people live their
lives the way they want I think you can
get a little headway there but i but it
is tough it is tough for sure well
fortunately we're recording this so you
can take a southern post if you want to
I don't take nothing you know I don't
want to out you here but I mean I look
over to the control room and there's in
America there's an American segment they
got a big American for Americans like
that vintage for like you know a lot of
beautiful things but here's what that
tells me
seeing that flag in the background tells
me that you love this country and that
you care about this country and that you
would like for the citizens in this
country to have the most optimal
outcomes they possibly can what how we
get there is the subject of discussion
very alive there but your motivation
from my value said your motivation is is
the same as my motivation so I don't so
I could talk to you all day about all
kinds of things and not ever get heated
about it because I could get excited
about it but never angry about it
because I perceive your motivations to
be the same as mine and I try with all
my might to make sure that my
motivations are are worthy you know that
they're that they're decent motivations
that they're that they're not selfish or
they're not exclusionary or they're not
any of these things they're they're the
things that you could answer for and and
not have to blush
you know so you're telling me that as a
Republican and someone on the right
you're not an evil racist bigoted
homophobic llama phob
give me a couple other photos
arachnophobia I made the case before and
I'll just give it to you as an example
here I genuinely think I I was one of
the things they yelled at me a lot about
it and that University was that it said
that black lives matter is not a serious
movement and that I cared more about
black people's lives and the black lives
matter people do now that's a
provocative statement I understand that
but the data for 2014 shows the total
number of black homicides in the country
of the total number of blacks killed in
this country in 2014
four percent were by policemen under any
circumstances it's not four percent of
the hands up that's four percent
shooting a police I was a deaf death by
police officers four percent and when
you have a political movement that is
that is determined to make not it's not
just making a Mulville of the four
percent because there there is some
signal in there there are some bad cops
so that that's a legitimate point that
needs to be raised but when when
everything you do is about this four
percent of your problem and ninety-six
percent of the problem you're not only
ignoring you're suppressing when
somebody points out to the fact hey you
know you're putting all this effort on
to four percent most of which is not
even up to discussion you know it's a
gun fight or something
and you're leaving ninety-six percent
out here that tells me you're not a
serious movement I don't want to know
why and then you look at things like
Detroit's been governed by Democrats
uninterrupted mayors and City Council's
for 60 years Atlanta's like a hundred
and thirty-eight years something like
this you it takes courage and I don't
mean to blow myself up over this it
takes courage to say that if somebody
has to point this out that somebody has
to point out where the problem really is
and I know what's coming for me when I
say that you know I know it but it has
to be said because people are getting
killed and they're not getting killed
where we live here in Santa Monica or
run yeah I'm wearing it so not where the
problem is yeah it's easy to talk about
these things and it's easy to put a
bumper sticker on your car and hold up a
sign and purchase all the rest of it but
meanwhile every week in Chicago five or
six people are being killed they're
mostly black people they're being killed
because of these policies are being
killed because of all of the economic
decay all the graft all the corruption
all of it the people dying
hundreds of them every year in every one
of these major cities and that's not an
accident and it's not a coincidence so
okay so I get it so you're you're you're
putting your ass on the line I mean that
that's what any of us that are to take
unpopular positions do so you're you're
putting your butt on the line to say
something like that when you've made
headway with people have you been able
to get someone to go wait a minute that
if Atlanta has had Democratic mayor's
for X amount of years or Chicago or
wherever and this is where all this
crime and murder is happening this is
where people are not moving upward and
all that how have you been able to reach
people on that because it could it seems
like it's almost like it's almost the
reverse of reason in a way because
people are just they just hold that
belief they just hold a belief that
somehow it's the evil Republicans or
something that are that are doing this
this is the racist but let me let me
just go just a slightly off to the sides
that because I think the best way to
answer that is is like this one I
realized that people wanted to read what
I was writing was just on a blog and
stuff and when I started to do actual
political commentary it became clear to
me pretty early but I thought my job was
to change people's minds was to convince
them of things but very quickly after
having gone to a bunch of speaking
events I think this is different for
conservatives than it is for liberals I
realized that a requirement that
superseded changing people's minds was I
had to I had to pass ammunition to
people who and and not just ammunition
but comfort to people who had been under
fire for a long time that that my
primary job was was to was to remind
people that we call conservatives in the
country today that they're not nuts that
they're not evil that they're not all of
these things and provide the evidence
that that is the case so I realized
early that while it would have been nice
to be a diplomat mostly my job was to go
up and down the line and hand out
ammunition cartridges you know and and
and stop people from being so filled
with despair because I don't think it's
accidental but even if it is one of the
things that that is applied against
conservatives is this cultural idea that
you're a dinosaur and you're all these
horrible and moral things and that's the
entire purpose because if we start
arguing
you're in trouble so there are a lot of
people out there and and what the comets
I was getting were not so much you
change my mind but bill you finally put
words into what I've been feeling my
whole life and you finally allow me to
talk to somebody at the you know the
water cooler or whatever you've given
you the arguments I knew these things
were true I just didn't know how to
express them and that that became my
primary motivation now if that is your
motivation you're going to take a
different rhetorical tack than you are
if you're actually going to try and
convert people and I would like to be in
converting people mode but I felt that I
felt that that the left needed the same
kind of ridicule that the right has been
getting the whole time and because I'm a
former I was never what you'd call a
progressive bitings always left the
country military business owner of it
but I my first vote was for Walter
Mondale Wow and it was because he said
he was going to raise taxes huh yeah
you've come you've come a long way so to
speak and and this is not an effort to
indicate that people who don't hope my
positions are wrong but I can tell you
what interests me the most is I cannot
believe looking back on things how
passionately I believed in things that I
knew nothing about nothing yeah that's
almost the key to being really
passionate about things really well I
don't know that much about it I think
that's not true I've accepted as you've
gotten as you've gotten more experience
more enlightened me too I find that the
the truth that the pachinko balls of
events tend to fall weather where you
expect them to fall and I personally now
this is more of a conservative statement
but I personally like the ability to say
one thing and then do the same thing I
don't have to call for higher taxes and
until my accountants take every
deduction that he possibly needs you
know I don't have to do any of that
right and what you're saying that
probably will most progressives or just
certainly what most celebrities are
doing I mean that Damon says oh we
should raise taxes and I'm rich I'll pay
the highest percentage of taxes ok Matt
but first of all you instead of going on
with 13 million you know you go in with
10 but there are people are struggling
and so on and you're pretty much we know
you're going into your accounting paying
the course right but Matt I know and you
no they don't know that that paramount
doesn't write a check pay to the order
Matt Damon 12 million dollars they're
ready Chiclets says pay to end the
Enterprises LLC right twelve million
dollars and then the business pays for
your house your car all your travel
everything they give you enough money to
you know to go grocery shopping on and
so on and you pay tax on that yeah and
so this is the essence of it I just like
you don't have a problem with that
actually I don't know prob your table
with the hypocrisy paradox no no no of
course not I don't have a problem with
that at all yeah they're taken about
half of what I make half and and here's
the thing and this is very enlightening
having Sibylla very much from Russia
because Natasha would say to me she
watched me write these checks to the IRS
saying what are you getting so what he
means well in Russia we have free health
care we have free college we have free
housing basically all these things paid
for by the state and they take 25
percent of what we make and I was a
little embarrassed out of that but but
what what the kind of things that really
affect me are I try to put myself in
other people's shoes and I know I know a
lot of people on the left think that
that people in business are very
rapacious and people in government are
very kind but I look around at the
condition of the roads for example in
Los Angeles and I think about the amount
of money that's being spent and it
seemed to me that if these were kind
people
the roads are be in great shape and the
public sector retirement benefits would
be quite small and just to really
personalize that this tiny little road
that separates our two Studios is it
absolute dump its third world I mean
it's a dump the exit that we're off okay
over here you know it is literally a
dump and there's garbage and my fiancee
is shocked by it because like everybody
else in Russia never was around the
world for that matter you grew up with
America America's the land where the
streets are paved with gold she sees all
this garbage on the streets in Los
Angeles and she's quite struck by it
yeah it's so interesting what you said a
moment ago about many burnout was bad we
can keep that vodka by the way where
there's a Russian theme here they're
sweet I do really like them it's not
really us but at the fact that you were
pouring either wage there's a little
thing about your hair
very much there is a little MDMA in
there though
a little MDMA that's the technical term
for ecstasy is that right yeah enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]